Speaker 1: Ron DeSantis recently pulled the
publicity stunt in Chicago and the governor
of the state of Illinois, where Chicago is
didn't like it and he's fired. Going back
and firing back viciously. What happened
is that Florida Governor Ron DeSantis,
in what appears to be a pre-presidential
run announcement tour, has been going. He
went to Staten Island. He also went to Chicago
and he spoke to the Fraternal Order of Police
Lodge number seven on Monday night in Elmhurst,
which is a suburb of Chicago. And at that event,
Ron DeSantis went after J.B. Pritzker,
the Democratic governor of Illinois,
for his criminal justice policies, saying the
Safety act and other Illinois policies are
the woke ification of public safety. Now, this is
an incredibly inaccurate claim by Ron DeSantis,
but J.B. Pritzker, who does not mess
around viciously but accurately attacked
Ron DeSantis. Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: The truth is that we
actually have a much better education system
in Illinois than they have true in Florida,
we're ranked higher than they are. U.S. News and
World Report ranked K-12 education in Illinois,
sixth in the country and number one
among the largest states in the country.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 4:
So he's got nothing to brag about when it comes
to education. So? So he moves on and tries to
use this word Wolk to describe everything.
He doesn't even know what the word means,
and he has no definition of it. It's just anything
he doesn't like is Wokeism. True. And all I can
tell you is that I don't know what that means.
And frankly, what I can say about Illinois is
that we're a state that cares about equity.
We're a state that cares about our families.
Speaker 1: That's woke. Caring about your
family and equity. That's what he means by woke.
Speaker 4: Making the investments that are
required so that our youngest children will
do better and better. And I'm really excited
about the direction of our state as opposed to
a state where they don't make the investments
that are necessary to lift up their education
system or their health care system.
Speaker 1: So Pritzker is, of course,
completely correct. Now, the tough talk from
Pritzker is being suggested, could be because
he's planning potentially to run for president if
Biden doesn't run, or maybe even if he does, it's
sort of unclear. But Pritzker, his name has kind
of been floating around as a possible contender.
But put that aside for a second. Okay. The truth
is that even if you put aside education where
Illinois is light years ahead of Florida, that's
absolutely the case. Put aside talk about the
primary subject matter here. Remember, DeSantis
was speaking to police about law enforcement and
so on and so forth. The right loves to talk about
the dystopian war zone that is Illinois because
of Chicago specifically. And it's absolutely true
that Chicago does have a significant gang and gun
crime issue. We've talked about how easy it is,
by the way, to go over the border into Indiana 40
minutes and then go back with guns that you can
easily obtain in Indiana. We've talked. But put
that put all of that aside for a second. Despite
Florida having the lax gun laws and laws that
give police more latitude and all these different
things, and despite the allegation that Illinois
is just so backwards on crime, the reality is that
Illinois and Florida have really similar violent
crime rates. They have different populations.
But if you look at per capita violent crime,
it's something like it's 390 per 100,000 people
in Florida and 420 per 100,000 people in Illinois.
Yes, Illinois has a slightly higher violent
crime rate, but the truth is they're both
right in the middle, around the 2025, you know,
out of 50 states. So to put it a different way.
Even though if you ask Ron DeSantis, Florida's
doing everything right on crime, law enforcement
and guns, and Illinois is doing everything
wrong on crime, law enforcement and guns, they
have almost identical violent crime rates. Which
really makes you wonder, is Ron DeSantis really
doing everything right? Is J.B. Pritzker really
doing anything wrong? Because those are pretty
damn weak numbers to demonstrate that that's the
case. Good for J.B. Pritzker. I like the guy. I
am not as familiar with him as as on policy as I
could be. But he has always struck me as decent
and willing to use the sort of language, rhetoric
and tone against these lying Republicans that I
think we need more of and that we've seen from
only only a handful of prominent Democrats. Let's
take a very quick break. All of the clips I played
for you here will be on our YouTube channel at
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show. And they
will also be on the Spanish YouTube channel For
those who prefer the Spanish language version of
this show at David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.